à la tombée de la nuit dans les rues de
Kiev les sources de lumière se font de
plus en plus rares certains quartiers
sont plongés dans l'obscurité presque
totale plus d'électricité dans cet
immeuble par exemple c'est le deuxième
jour consécutif que cette habitant subit
des coupures
on a été le réfrigérateur pour
économiser l'électricité les habitants
obligés de s'adapter aux mesures
d'économie d'énergie
on utilise le balcon
regardez pour garder les produits au
frais
très bientôt chez certains voisins la
lumière est toujours allumée la mairie
de Kiev a instauré des coupures
tournantes de 4 heures le chauffage
central aussi est rationné alors que la
température dehors frôle déjà les zéro
degrés on a beaucoup de couverture pour
l'hiver quand il fait froid on met des
habits bien chaud à la maison c'est sûr
qu'on est plus en T-shirt chez nous
jusqu'à ce qu'il fasse moins 10 ou moins
15 degrés il faudra bien qu'on tienne
pendant l'hiver le thermomètre peut
descendre jusqu'à moins 20 degrés ces
deux dernières semaines 30% des
infrastructures énergétiques ont été
détruits l'armée russe concentre ses
frappes contre les centrales
ukrainiennes résultats le pays manque
aujourd'hui d'électricité
sans parler du réseau de distribution
très endommagé dans les zones
directement concernées par les combats
comme ici à irpin dans cette ville de la
banlieue de Kiev les affrontements se
sont pourtant terminés en avril dernier
aujourd'hui on va s'occuper des câbles
on doit réparer deux lignes électriques
le cabinet
7 mois plus tard le réseau n'est pas
complètement rétabli le rythme des
destructions est impossible à suivre
même les sièges des entreprises
énergétiques sont devenues des cibles
pour l'armée russe
comme vous le voyez la majorité des
employés de faire le télétravail et
l'entreprise leur permet de le faire
parce qu'on pense que c'est plus sûr
qu'il travaille chez eux
la principale entreprise privée du
secteur essaie de faire face mais
d'après son PDG les mesures d'économie
d'énergie ne suffisent pas l'Ukraine a
besoin d'aide de matériel pour réparer
ses installations et d'armes pour les
protéger
le problème le plus important c'est
qu'on n'a pas assez de défense entière
aériennes c'est le seul moyen pour nous
de stabiliser la situation et de
protéger nos infrastructures
l'Ukraine va-t-elle peut-elle tenir sans
gaz sans électricité sans chauffage le
président volody merzelinski averti
qu'il pouvait y avoir une nouvelle vague
migratoire
ukrainienne vers l'Union européenne pour
fuir le froid et l'hiver glacial